well now some shocking honesty from far
left squad congresswoman corey bush who
is saying that she could have all the
private security she wants but uh that
we need to defund the police for we the
little people i guess all of us you know
not her
take a look
you want to see me die you know because
that could be the alternative so either
i spent seventy thousand dollars on
private security over the last few
months and i'm here standing here
standing now and able to speak able to
help save 11 million people
from being evicted or i could possibly
have a death attempt on my life if i end
up spending 200 000 if i spend 10 10 10
more dollars on it you know what i get
to be here to do the work so suck it up
and defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police and put
that money into social safety nets
because we're trying to save lives
would you like to see the threats i get
i'm sure they're they might shock you
anyway i guess safety security is only
the aristocrats in the swamp and the
sewer and not for the rest of us joining
us now with reaction congressman dan
crenshaw leo 2.0 terrell congressman um
you know
probably all of us
right now i would assume leo it's
probably happened to you dad it's
probably happened to you i've been doing
this 33 years it's happened more than a
few occasions with me uh yeah you get
threats if you're a public figure and
you exp express political opinions dan
yeah that's right and and look i'm happy
that she has private security but i just
wonder if if the citizens of st louis
could afford 70 000 a year exactly but i
wonder if the citizens that she
represents could actually afford 70 000
a year in private security and god knows
they need it st louis is one of the most
dangerous cities in america you have a 1
in 51 chance of being a victim of a
crime in st louis there's been 109
murders there this year and a hundred of
those victims have been black people
okay and they're not being killed by
cops they're being killed by criminals
and murderers and you know who chases
criminals and murderers well it's cops
and that's exactly who she wants to
defund this goes directly against where
her community actually wants and needs
81 percent of the black community favors
the same or more policing and here's the
big takeaway here we have to do away
with this notion that that the democrats
are not this radical party they are a
radical party this isn't some fringe
activist that you just played on tv that
was a democrat member of congress and a
very popular one at that right member of
the squad they have the highest social
media following they have real influence
into the democrat party defunding the
police is not just some radical talking
point it's happened across the country
and in american cities murders have gone
up 33 percent this year it's because of
defunding the police it's because of
this sort of social justice bail reform
where they're letting criminal criminals
out on bail instead of putting them in
jail and our communities are being
killed and hurt and she doesn't seem to
care she doesn't seem to care she relies
on these horrible social justice talking
points and she's doing exactly what her
what her citizens and the people she
represents don't want
leo i want to be very clear i want
congresswoman bush every every elected
official i don't care what your politics
are they we need to protect our elected
officials
but we also need neighborhoods that are
safe and secure and that have law and
order because without those things you
cannot pursue happiness can you and the
hypocrisy is fine she'll get the private
security will pay for it but she's
simultaneously defunding the police that
protects the rest of the country
let me first of all say i agree i don't
want any harm
to occur to congresswoman bush but how
dare she she talks about flaunting 70 80
100 000 or her private security and what
about the black people in chicago l.a in
washington dc they don't have a hundred
thousand dollars they're just trying to
put food on the table and she is not
helping black people she's gas like
gaslighting black people she needs to
pick a side either she helps the black
people in her community or she picks
goes with the criminals it is insulting
for her to sit there and say she's doing
the work she's doing the work for no one
she is destroying black communities by
taking away their only line of defense
police black people want police it's for
her to go up there and talk about her
ability to spend 70 80 100 000
who in her community have a hundred
thousand dollars to spend it is
insulting
she doesn't represent anyone and she
doesn't represent black people she
represents criminals
when we come back thank you leo thank
you congressman crenshaw hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else